The data that we keep on our storage
devices can be very valuable. And there
may be times when we want to be
absolutely sure that nobody else can
gain access to this data, especially on
storage drives that we're no longer
using. And one of the most effective
ways to provide this type of assurance
is physically destroying the storage
device. And there are many different
ways to provide this type of storage
destruction. One of these ways is to use
a drill or a hammer or anything that
would destroy the media itself. It's
relatively easy to drill a hole through
the platters of a hard drive and that
would effectively prevent us from
recovering any data from this hard
drive. If you have a lot of drives that
you need to destroy, you might want to
use some industrial equipment such as a
shredder. You throw the drives into the
shredder and it will grind them up into
smaller metal pieces. For spinning hard
drives, you could also use a very
powerful magnet known as a degasser.
This will remove the magnetic field
associated with this drive. It removes
all of the data from the drive and it
renders the hard drive itself unusable
going forward. Unfortunately, deaussing
does not work for SSD drives or flash
memory drives. And one way of ensuring
that this drive will never be used again
is to throw it in an incinerator.
But there may be times when you would
like to repurpose this drive. It's a
perfectly working hard drive or a
perfectly working SSD. So, we should be
able to delete all of the data on that
drive in a way that we can feel is
secure and would prevent anybody gaining
access to any of that previous data. One
of the ways to do that would be to use a
file level overriding. For example, on
the Microsoft Windows CIS internal site,
you can download a utility called SDEE.
This will securely delete files and
prevent anyone from recovering that data
later. And of course, you can perform a
similar function across the entire drive
using specialized utilities such as
DBAN, that stands for Derek's boot and
Nuke. This will delete all of the data
across the entire drive and allow you to
use that drive again. These utilities
work very well for a hard drive, but
unfortunately an SSD can often store
information outside the scope of a file
system, rendering these types of file
level deletion utilities relatively
worthless. Another way to delete
everything on a drive is to format it.
When you receive a hard drive from the
factory, it has been preformatted with
something called a low-level format.
This is usually a feature or a function
that's not available to the end user and
is usually only done in the factory.
When we receive the drive, we're able to
put a file system on that drive and we
can format that drive with the file
system. There are a number of different
formatting options available. One is a
standard format. You might also see this
referred to as a quick format. This will
build the index for the file system. It
will install a boot sector on the drive,
but it's only clearing out the index to
the data, and it's not actually deleting
the data that's in the other part of the
drive. If you do have the right
software, you will still be able to
recover all of the data after a quick
format. The default format type in
Windows is called a standard format or
regular format. This will not only clear
out your index, but it will go through
every sector on the drive and overwrite
all of the data that was previously
there. This does take a bit of time to
go through every single sector that's on
the drive, but once it's done, you have
a completely clean drive and no way to
recover that previous data.
Obviously, physical destruction of the
drive is one way that you can be assured
that none of that data will be available
again. But it may seem a bit of a waste
to take a perfectly working drive and
destroy it. But if you work for a
financial services company or you work
in healthcare, you might want to be
assured that no one would ever gain
access to any of that sensitive data. So
although the end of this destruction
process makes a device that can't be
used anymore, we can be absolutely sure
that that data will always remain safe.
And in some cases, you might be legally
required to destroy that drive to ensure
that all of that information is secure
and that nobody else can get their hands
on that sensitive data.
If you have one or two drives a month
that need to be destroyed, you might be
able to do that yourself with a hammer
or with a drill. But if you're a large
organization that has thousands of
drives that you need to destroy every
month, you might want to hire a third
party to provide that service. Of
course, you still need to be assured
that all of that data will be properly
destroyed, and you need some way to hand
this drive off to the third party, but
still get reassurances that all of that
information is no longer available.
These thirdparty providers will commonly
provide a certificate of destruction.
This is a document that shows that they
received a particular drive, they
destroyed the drive, and they have
evidence to show that all of that data
is no longer available. If you're using
a third party to provide this type of
destruction service, you might want to
also require that they provide a
certificate of destruction.
This might be a bigger problem than you
may realize. In 2019, there was a study
from Blanco and OnTrack that took 159
storage drives that they purchased on
eBay and evaluated what type of data was
on those drives. 42% of those used
drives had some type of sensitive data
on the drive itself. 66 of those drives
had some type of data. 25 of those
drives had personally identifiable
information. And it was many different
types of data that they found on these
drives. Information from a travel
company, freight company information,
student papers from a university, and
video, audio, and other personal media
files. This is another reason why it's
so important to consider all of your
options when it comes to decommissioning
your storage drives.